[Music]
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
today's wisner gallery online tour my
name is shannon rose mcauliffe and i'm
the manager of the student arts programs
here at mit
i'm joined by sarah herzl she's the
coordinator of the weesner student art
gallery
and allahe ahmadi who is an
interdisciplinary artist from tehran
iran
is a 2020 graduate of mit in the
department of electrical
engineering and computer science and
she's currently a graduate student
in that very same program she learned
photography as an undergraduate student
in the department of
arts culture and technology allah's
project has been sponsored by the
council for the arts at mit
also known as kamet and after a brief
introduction by sarah herzl about the
exhibition
allah will lead us through the virtual
show via her screen share
you're welcome to view this the
exhibition on her website which is going
to be put into the chat on your sidebar
after this tour please feel free to join
us for some questions and answers
feel free to submit your questions using
the chat box use the raise hand function
and we'll open the floor for some really
lovely discussion
and without further ado um before we
begin my friend sarah has a couple of
words
thank you so much shannon rose for all
everything it has been a sincere
pleasure
working with allahe on this exhibition i
want to extend my particular thanks to
heidi erickson
our graphic designer and web creator for
mit's office of the arts
we are grateful for the generous support
of many members of the staff
of the office of the arts and canon
before we begin i want to acknowledge
how
elijay beautifully demonstrates the
importance of the arts
at mit her subjects are very
representative
of the creativity and depth of our
community
eli haye is not just a photographer she
is something of a documentarian
and a social artist for whom
interpersonal connection
has high creative value she
invites her participants and her
audience to bring their full selves
into the communities they study live and
play in
nurturing the success of women and
others in settings such as mit
is important work and it's exciting that
elahe can
use the art of photography to tell
stories that allow for openness
and connection she uses her own
challenges to nurture others
and as many of her collaborators will
attest she is a joy
to work with i am very pleased to
introduce
allah amadi
thank you sarah and shannon for amazing
introduction
and organizing this event i'm
so happy this is finally happening i'm
so excited that all of you could join us
for the opening of this exhibition this
project has been
a huge part of my life for the past
three years and i'm so excited to
finally share the results with all of
you
i have put together a video about the
journey of trapped
and i don't want to spoil the rest so
let's just watch it i hope you all enjoy
it
[Music]
welcome to trapped exhibition virtually
hosted by
visner gallery at mit
my name is alahe and i am the director
of trapped
this project started in fall 2018
as a final project for my intro to
photography class
taught by laura bellady at that time
i was dealing with a lot of challenges
in my personal life that
led me to a very dark place but i found
photography and dark room to be my
saviors
in the class traps started with me
expressing how
i was feeling at the moment trapped by
all the society's expectations
all the laws that kept me from seeing my
family
the pressure of being a female in
engineering and
having to suppress my femininity
and being trapped in a relationship that
getting out of it
meant being a failure so i asked a
friend or two
to be my model and help me capture my
feelings
i showed the first couple of photos to
laura and she told me
this doesn't have to be just about you
it can be about all women i'll give you
another
week and go see where this goes
i am so grateful she said that because
if it wasn't for her i would have had
the courage to ask people to take time
out of their lives to just model for me
but
i gave it a shot i started opening up to
my friends
telling them how i was feeling and
little did i know that i wasn't alone
from my friends back home to my close
friends and peers at mit
to people i just met at a bar or party
we all felt trapped one way or another
and it was then that i realized i need
to let people
know how we women are feeling
i need to take a step into creating
a safe space for everyone to be able to
share their experiences
and for others to ask questions about it
i believe that talking about the issues
and letting
others know is a good step
toward creating a society that treats
everyone equally so i did
i made trapped to be the voice of
all women from all backgrounds
[Music]
the process would usually start with a
conversation in some setting
that someone would either show interest
in the project
or i would think of an idea or two for
the person and i would
propose them to collaborate with me
before each photo shoot
i would tell my participant to wear
whatever they want
it just has to be all black and then
after what i would call a heart-to-heart
conversation
about her challenges the photo shoot
would happen
each photo shoot was unique sometimes i
would find a place
on campus or i would go to their houses
or we would just go to streets and
sometimes it just happened at the moment
and suddenly i had the perfect shot
but the photoshop wasn't just about that
it was about the whole experience
me letting myself to be vulnerable
around my female and non-binary peers
them appreciating my honesty and also
opening up about their experience and
us connecting on a deeper level
and then we would throw ideas off of
each other until we were happy with a
shot
[Music]
once the photoshoot was over it was time
for post-processing the images
i used both digital and 35 millimeter
film
to shoot the photos i would spend hours
in the dark room
developing and printing the photos or in
the digital lab
doing some minor edits and printing the
photos
one of the most rewarding parts of the
process
was bringing the moments i had with the
participants
to life through the photos
this project not only helped me to get
through the hard times
but it also helped many of the
participants to
start being more vocal and expressive
with the challenges they're dealing with
on a daily basis
one of my participants posted the photos
on her
instagram and she came out to her family
and friends
about her open marriage and sexuality
which it made me so happy
and proud to get to be a part of that
the project grew not because i was
pushing it
but because our voices through the
photos
were so powerful
that it made people feel safe
to open up and talk about it all of it
the how our communities we grow up in
suffered from gender biases how
gender bias affected our life choices
how we felt shut down in meetings and
projects
how we felt judged by the way we dress
or by our body
after 16 unique photo shoots
with different women i decided in
february 2020
that i was ready to wrap up the project
so i called in
all the people who participated before
all the people who were
who showed interest at any time for a
final
group photo shoot i gave them the same
instruction
told them all of them that you need to
wear something black
whatever you're comfortable with put on
as much makeup as you want or don't
do your hair or don't just show up with
something that you're comfortable with
something that is
you so i told everybody to show up
at 10 am saturday this was
different from all the photo shoots that
i did before because
it wasn't a one-on-one something that i
was like
comfortable with and it was like a
comfortable intimate setup
it was a group setting that
everybody from different backgrounds i
asked all of them to get together so
before that all of the photo shoots
i didn't plan them much beforehand
because i knew
once we get into it we will throw ideas
off of each other and the photo shoot
would just happen
but this one was different so what i did
was
i took all the prints that i had
my camera all the setup just showed up
where i was supposed to show up
and you should have been there
it was amazing just
seeing all these awesome
beautiful smart
strong woman get together
in this set like day and
most of them didn't even know like other
people like maybe
like every person knew like one or two
other person but
for a lot of them it was like a kind of
an uncomfortable setup too because
like nobody did modeling professionally
it was something like new for all of
them but
we all shared one thing and it was
we believed and trapped we believed that
traps
is something that can help all of us
voice
our feelings our struggles
and that was what brought
everybody together on that day and
it was amazing
so at the beginning of the
session i put all the prints down
and i told everybody take whatever print
that you feel close to
and write something on the back of it or
draw something or
do whatever you feel comfortable
something
like if that photo spoke to you and
that's why you picked it
then you have something to say and that
was for me to just like
get everybody in that head space and
also have some time to like
put prepare the setup
and and the results were
just fabulous
to see how other people like
[Music]
felt something with somebody else
who maybe was from another world
like was born somewhere else had a
completely different background
but there was still one connection there
in my opinion that was the best way to
warm up everybody
uh let everybody to be more comfortable
loosen up and get to that headspace
and we started shooting we started
taking the group photos
um you can see them now in the
exhibition there
are i love them i mean i'm biased
but i think they look amazing just
seeing everybody's beautiful faces
the different outfits the different way
that they put themselves in the frame i
i didn't tell them what to do
all i told them was exist do whatever
feels comfortable for you
if that means talking with somebody else
that you know
do that i don't care i want you
to be in the head space you are now
and express yourself somehow with your
body
and i couldn't believe it
when i looked at my watch and it was 4pm
and i was shooting six hours non-stop
it was i think for me that was like one
of the best days i've ever had
doing anything like six hours not even
realizing how time passed
and i was happy i was jumping everywhere
and like
looking at the photos loving everything
that was happening there
and it was amazing to see
i wasn't the only one enjoying myself
other people were also like
really enjoying talking to other people
getting each other's contact info
um just connecting and kind of
networking too
and i think
it was the best way to wrap
up this photo with this project because
that was what i wanted i wanted to bring
people
together i wanted to create a safe space
and i wanted people to
see other women realize they're not
alone
and be proud of the struggles
and how far they came
and even though most of the times
everything is against us
[Music]
hi i'm alexa i'm from san francisco and
i graduated
mit last year in core62 i'm currently a
program manager
in cameron depth hardware in the bay
area
i had the honor and privilege of doing a
photo shoot for trapped with the lahay
the photo shoot was such an awesome
experience
it was a glimpse into the crazy creative
mind that is la
hey we were just bouncing ideas off of
each other like what if you blur this
with motion what if you
put this pattern on your face what if
you turned around it was all these
what-ifs flying around
and i think part of the reason it was so
easy and fun is because
she's my really good friend and it was a
really comfortable space for
experimentation
and i think the other part of it is
because she's such a great photographer
and she turns the world into her art
so effortlessly i think trapped
as a whole is a set of
feelings and emotions to me it's
isolation
despair and hopelessness it's this
feeling of
being where you don't want to be and not
knowing how to get out
i think that's somewhere that we've all
been to a certain extent
i think that's also the reason why this
project expanded to what it is
now it's because the theme is so
universal
yet also so personal to each individual
thanks to lahai for
letting me be a part of this and i hope
everyone enjoys it as much as i do
hi my name is ellie i was born in iran
and raised in the u.s
i currently live in los angeles
california and i graduated from boston
university in 2020.
i was a part of the trap photo shoot and
i'm extremely grateful that i was a part
of the trap photo shoot
because it just means so many different
things to me as a young girl
growing up in iran and the us and
hearing from all different types of
people
how women should feel and how they
should look
and how they should act and how they
should react and then thinking
that's not how i look that's not how i
feel that's not how i want to act or
react to certain situations
and just this trapped project was a way
for me to be able to kind of break down
some of those stereotypes and
show how i am and what i feel
the photo shooting process was something
completely new to me
and elaha is an amazing photographer and
she made me feel so comfortable the
entire time
as someone who doesn't always like how
she looks in pictures and
always picks out her flaws the way that
the pictures came out
and just the entire process it was
amazing
and i just felt so comfortable and
confident and beautiful in those
pictures
even that's not how i always feel the
final photo shoot was definitely my
favorite
seeing this beautiful group of women of
all different
backgrounds and ages and cultures coming
together as the culmination
of this trapped project and just seeing
what track meant to them and hearing
their stories and their backgrounds
and sharing my story it was just so
empowering and
amazing and i'm extremely grateful to
have been a
part of this project and it really does
mean a lot to a lot of people
[Music]
and now today i am
so proud to present you the trapped
exhibition
a project that would have not been
possible without every single
person supporting me and
pushing me motivating me to move forward
it was an honor to work with all
these amazing people who worked
on this project with me and to create
a project that will hopefully give
some people courage to speak up
and be who they want to be
and do what their heart desires
and now the moment we have all been
waiting for
or at least i have is finally here
i would like to welcome you to the
exhibition of
trout the first thing you will see
as you walk into this exhibition is
the photo of a person in their most
vulnerable position surrounded by a
light
where there is nothing but darkness in
the outside
i see this photo as a great opener for
what you're about to experience
as you walk through the exhibition
then if you scroll down you will
find a description of the project
and what you're about to experience and
how you can experience this exhibition
if you scroll down more you can then
find the name a photo and a bio
of different participants you can
scroll into the to see
what different parts who different
participants are where they're coming
from
what their story is how they felt
related to this project and
you can then see their experience
by clicking on this button if you scroll
down more
you can then find a video of me
telling you about how this project is
started
and a series
of the group photo shoots
and the list of the names of all the
peoples
who contributed to this project and then
there's a navigator that can help you
navigate
to different walls of the exhibition
now let's go and see
alexa's experience
when you enter the participants wall
you can see all of their photos
by clicking right and left
into this slider you can then
scroll down and see
their walls where you can find their bio
and all of their photos next to each
other
some photos have reflections which are
in the form of
poetry or a short essay
next to the photos these reflections are
written by other artists you can also
click on the photos and see them
isolated
once you've enjoyed that participant's
wall
he can then navigate to
see the next participants
please make sure you visit all
the different walls and see
where all these amazing people are
coming from
what is their story and how they relate
to travel project at any time if you
want to go back
to the exhibition main page
you can just click here and that would
take you
to the opening page or
as i would like to call it the opening
wall
[Music]
in the end i want to thank all of you
for joining me today for this opening
i also want to thank everyone who
participated in this project
one way or another i want to thank
ghoulie for designing the exhibition and
also
my amazing professors and mentors laura
and giselle for helping me mentoring me
and guiding me through this
journey thank you
[Music]
i want you to like do this exactly i
feel like the irony that your fear
[Music]
be said is loud honestly
oh you look so
it cute be crazy
[Music]
thank you for watching it wow i tried so
hard not to cry
[Laughter]
the behind the scene helped
[Laughter]
now i want to jump and start the q
a by asking a question from one of the
amazing participants who could make it
here today
uh dodo i'm so glad you could make it
here today
i have a question for you i was
wondering
i was wondering share your experience
with trapped
and how your photos made you feel
yeah of course uh you know i was
watching in the video
where some of the other participants
shared as well
so i'll try to live up to that level
of insight so yeah thank you for
inviting me
this has really been a journey
you know for for you and all the
participants i know
for myself actually it's a journey that
you know started very early when i was
much younger
and trapped very promptly you know at
the time a couple years ago
helped me put words to it put an image
to it
um and then something that continues
after
trapped i think for for my own
reflection to grow
after that so you know i'm very happy to
see you again and also share that with
everyone here
um so first of all i guess the
experience itself i would say
it was very fun and reflective
fun being that you know from the video i
think everybody
saw that it was a very collaborative
process um you know i didn't feel like i
was
the model you know doing whatever elahe
wanted me to do like that was
sort of you know like not the point of
the project right so i think
you ella had very intentionally wanted
it to be a thought partnership
and kind of play around with it right
like um it's a true collaboration
so um i love that we you know we're just
experimenting like the idea of kind of
half makeup you know it was sort of when
we were talking
at some point um i don't even know i
don't even remember who
popped up the idea but you know we went
with it when
i turned out really well so yeah so
the whole experience itself i think had
a lot of fun to it
but of course at the same time i think
because of your outreach
right it's helped me really
start to reflect on this feeling that
i've had
for a really long time and
personally you know i i also i was a
girl
in tech or math very very early on
i went through this whole competitive
math track came from china you know
to us for high school and then mit
and you know on top of all that i also
reflected myself to be
an artist at heart who's studying
engineering
at mit uh who has an interest in
business
um who you know like growing up in a
society where i had a lot of
expectations of women um you know not
necessarily
in tech or math or art uh
for that matter um so i think yeah the
you know i i felt like through the
project
uh i was able to really see it
you know through the power of arts like
in one
two three images right and a couple
short blurbs
what this conflict has been about
and you know i think we coined it that
it was the struggle between the outside
expectations
and my own way of looking at myself
the multiple multitudes multiple
identities that could exist
in the same person but we live
in a world of specialization you know we
live in the world
of putting a single label on people
but in fact i felt like i'm much more
than a single label and much more than
a specialized you know career and much
more than like
any part of me um so thank you for you
know jump starting that reflection i
would say
that reflection actually since college
has really in the past two
three years since i started working so i
worked for
about three years at a global consulting
firm
i just uh recently decided to
change my career into you know k-12
education
also professional coaching and i think
actually this whole reflection of who i
really am
right who i can be all the different
parts of me
really led me here right um i think
just even in in my previous career as a
consultant
um i was continuing to reflect
on how you know this outside
expectation of what you should you know
behave what you should look
uh you know the your job kind of your
job title becomes your only identity
right conclusion um and i was actually
very happy
that um that i could bring this kind of
discussion
to my colleagues to my teams you know to
the company itself we actually had a
discussion around
kind of multiple identity rates how
people
see themselves versus what what they
think the job
ex like requires them right to uh to be
perceived
and so yeah so these discussions
continue and
i think if i were to sum it up of how i
look at
this picture of me and of uh of your
wall you know home wall
picture as well um i would say
that it reminds me of a quote i saw
somewhere
is you know the darkness that we
experience
is not the darkness of the tomb but
rather the darkness of the womb
you know like we are to be born we're to
be awakened
uh we are the fact that we are doing
this project
experiencing these struggles and
conflicts and emotions
um is the start of something new and the
start
of you know the liberation of
all of us and so now i look at
these pictures i feel extremely hopeful
and you know so for me it has been yeah
like
the past three years and
the journey didn't start with the
project
it was very well captured with the
project
and it continued after the project
thank you so much dodo for sharing that
it was
it was amazing to hear thank you for
inviting yeah
you could make it um now
if um sarah if you want to take over
yeah i was just gonna say i think it's
time that we can invite
everyone into the conversation you're
welcome
to speak up or to put a question into
the chat we welcome
either one and we love to see videos on
for friends and family
so allah can see you
anyone who's got a question can you hear
me
yes thanks uh hi i'm mustafa and uh
so i have a question for ellare or i
like any of
any other of the participants here uh
i've been seeing the posters for the
exhibition on the social media and i
that that's that's the main reason i
joined the exhibition today and
was there's a question growing in my
mind and that's the
uh fact that like why the dark theme or
the black color is chosen
to represent the participants in this
uh exhibition like
what does exactly this color means and
what emotion this color
is going to express there so i told
everybody to wear whatever they were
comfortable with
so whatever it's them like for example
if um
i'm a person that i usually wear dresses
and that's
what i'm comfortable in that i wanted
the person to wear the dress or if
they're like
usually comfortable walking around with
jerseys and that's what i wanted them to
show up with
and and i think like in the final photo
shoot you can see that like
contrast of what are what different
women
are comfortable wearing and like
feel like that's that's their them
that's what they
are oh thank you very much that was a
great exhibition
yeah of course thank you for joining
i have a question about your
contribution in arts in your life at mit
were you surprised by what uh
prominence this kind of practice took in
your life
as a student was that something you
expected or was that a discovery for you
it was not something that i expected it
what i found so uh growing up i knew i
loved photography i would always like
take
a photo with my phone or like steal my
mom's camera
and take photos with that um so i knew i
liked it
but i realized how powerful
it can be in my photography class
again thanks to my amazing professors
who opened my eyes to like the power of
arts
and um and that was then that i realized
the issues that i care about um
i probably can contribute use doing
robotics and the engineering
that i'm studying and i'm practicing but
i realize there is like
something more power powerful with just
like a photo
that you can show it to different people
everybody would take something different
from it
and it's just so powerful because
there's like no right or wrong
know this or that it's this is what i'm
showing you
i put a lot of emotions in it now what
do you take out of it
and um and i think that was something
that
in photography and the visual arts that
i
started practicing i saw a lot more
than i ever saw in my engineering
classes or research
it's a good answer thanks really
interesting yeah
and since i'm here to moderate i want to
welcome anyone else to ask a question
you can also ask
of one of you know if anyone who
participated wants to speak up we'd love
to hear from you
um thank you for
um for your invitation to the opening
um it's very brave of you to
express yourself so publicly um my
question for you is that
you said that you were when you started
it it was a personal project
and then you realized that other people
were also
struggling with issues and you started
to um
invite them to also join this and feel
this experience with you
um so my question is that what made you
feel that the project was done
because it can go on forever and what
made you stop and decide that okay it's
time to wrap it up
uh that's a good question i think it was
a very hard call
to make um i think
one thing that i realized um
in in 2020 before i actually make the
call of
having the final photo shoot was that
i my goal was to
have a space for everybody to feel safe
and i felt like
my project maybe is also creating some
sort of
um gender
exclusiveness that i'm just making it
for women to
feel to like show the struggles of women
and show the struggles of female in the
society
and and i realized i wanted to be more
than that even though yes they're like
women have had a lot of struggles in the
history
we can just go and see how much like
bias has affected
all of us um but in the society that
we're living now
we know that the gender is not binary
anymore
we have like non-binary
identification and those people are also
having struggles of their
own and it's just like a wide range of
people
and just people having struggles uh and
i
wanted my next project to be more about
that
creating a safer space for everybody
creating um
something that everybody can contribute
to and
have other audiences to see that
and be like okay we need to be more
cautious
or like conscious of all of these issues
and we need to speak up about all of
these issues
um okay
thank you and um do you have anything in
your mind that you'd be
proceeding with your next project for
future
that's a good question
[Laughter]
um that's a good question that's my
answer
fair enough i actually have the same
question i was going to ask her what are
you going to do with your time now
not at this project it has its showcase
and it's over
yeah i know it's i'm going to sleep
um yeah i'm gonna do a lot of that and
once i have a lot of sleep i'll think
about something else to do
do you think that this project will
extend into your professional life
in any way any of the lessons that
you've learned would go into your
professional work i mean obviously
you're finishing your degree still
and yeah i think so i think
this project gave me a lot of courage to
just
talk to people as people
because um i think
sometimes it's just hard to see other
people as somebody else who's also
struggling and dealing with everything
that you're also dealing with
and just like i think
doing this project i would just like
start go to people and start talking to
them and be
like yeah there's this project that i'm
working on and
it would just open up the conversation
and help me to like get to know people
and connect to more people and and i
think that was like a
practice for me too to just like learn
how to talk to people
because as an or somebody who moved
from iran to u.s and as somebody who's
like english is my second language
it was a challenge for me to just like
talk to people when i
first moved to us and make friends and
network or just like in a party talk to
people
um and i think this project gave me a
really good medium and practice
and um i'm grateful
dodo has a question yeah
so i guess an on a related topic uh
how do you see arts you know maybe
photography obviously is a big part of
it or many other art forms
kind of play into you know your life
or a profession whether a professional
life or you know from this point on
what is the role of continuing kind of
to be an artist
right um what does that mean to you or
what's your plan around that
that's a that's a really great question
too um
these are actually things that i'm
actively thinking about like what am i
gonna do
next how is this gonna merge with my
engineering life
and i think the honest answer is that i
still don't know i'm still trying to
figure it out
but i think some ideas that i have now
is that i really enjoy
talking to different people bringing
different people from different
backgrounds together
and having them like connect and
have something amazing come out of it
and
and i think i want to use that to bring
people together
um whether it's going to be like an
engineering project an
art project or something completely
different
but i want to bring people together
because i
when i talk to people individually i can
see how amazing they are
and sometimes i can see how they're not
confident and they don't
see how amazing they are and
i want to be like if i can i want to be
able to tell them that you're
amazing like and then tell somebody else
who i know it's amazing be like
you two are awesome meet each other make
something
amazing and i think i could do a little
bit of that and trap
and i want to do more of that
very cool yeah can i get i can relate to
it because
uh yeah the power of art in that case is
very strong
yeah thank you yeah thank you for asking
you
i'd say the world needs you
needs more of that um
anyone else
this is really great uh thank you for
sharing
these pictures with us um and also
thanks for inviting
um i have one more question for you i
wanted to ask
uh for people wondering or people
debating uh
considering like incorporating arts into
um their other like known arts uh
professional lives or other things
what advice would you have for these
people
uh wanting to pursue art in addition to
anything else that you do
given that you have been able to do it
very successfully
thank you for saying that um i think
what i tell myself is that
if there is something that you want to
do
do it like if you want to take a date
out of your crazy schedule and just go
out and take photos
just do it and we all need
needed time like need a break we all
need a way to express everything that's
like building up
and i feel like with our lives
now it's like everything happening back
to back and like you don't have a time
to process anything you don't have a
time to like sit back and see what is
happening
and i think art for most of us is a way
to take out all the things that have
like
piling up in our
bodies in our mind and like just get it
out and
we need that like you need that as a way
to like stay sane and
be able to like um operate in your crazy
life so
if you have something that makes you
happy do it
even if you think it's gonna take up
from your life and like keep you from
doing your psets or research or whatever
it's not because it's gonna help you
take everything that's in your mind
out and then you can focus on the other
parts
more too like because you will have a
clear mind
and that will help you like 100
if it didn't come fight me i will
i will be responsible but okay
thanks for that thank you for asking me
i want to probably add something um
if if you have time go model for allah
it helps your self-confidence
yeah it it really does like for
i am really uncomfortable in photos i am
really uncomfortable
and uh just like aloha just like taking
two three random or
casual pictures of me i i felt
the confidence boost yeah she's she's
great
you can't separate her from this project
she's a very big part of this idea
like i it's it's not easy
as a i i don't at least i don't think
i'm not a photographer but i don't think
it's easy as a photographer to
make someone comfortable that you're
taking photos of and elohim is so good
at that
she's so good at that yeah so
thank you for your amazing music too
thanks both didn't know the music and
the movie
and in the opening was composed by arya
um and it was amazing yeah
it was some random
improvises
are he's also here right yeah
uh gobahar was the designer of the
exhibition
what you're about to see and thank you
so much for making that happen i tried
to like
change one or two things that i was
going crazy so
thank you so much for making it happen
of course thank you for all the
beautiful art i had such a good time
making it to the point where i'm
probably going to be making
more artist websites that was amazing
thank you
i'm super proud of you thank you i'm
glad you had
a good time
so we've got some really lively and
inspiring conversation happening i want
to encourage that to keep going
on but i'm also being sensitive to the
hour so
um i think we're going to wrap up the
official event
and we're going to thank everybody for
joining us thank you so much to allah
for this fantastic showing of trapped um
on that subject we'd like to encourage
everybody in here to visit the wiesner
gallery site and to
explore this exhibition and others at
your leisure
and um basically i think at this point
we can move into the after hours segment
so if you are friends family peers
colleagues anybody
and you want to stick around and chat
with allah and with each other we're
gonna keep this room
open feel free to unmute yourselves and
let the party continue
thank you all for coming today yes thank
you all so much have an awesome evening
thank you i also want to thank everybody
who joined me and joined us today
i really hope you enjoyed the exhibition
and
if you have time let's stick around and
talk
share stories
you